Do you hear me?
Yes, now I can hear you.
Okay, I have a problem with my teams, I guess. It took about a minute for me to get in this.
Meeting.
Are they, are they?
I am just dropping an email to Tanya.
Yeah, is the first time they're not joining in?
Oh yeah, I mean this is the first monthly call actually.
Okay, it says a week.
Earlier, we used to have biweekly.
OK, the Sarbjeet.
Yeah, I need, I need to change the invite, update the whole invite.
And, sir, I think we need we should pitch in for additional resource, because Casey is getting enough work now.
So is.
Utilization is pretty decent.
OK.
Okay.
There's something wrong with the invite clip. See? He responded.
Sir, same thing happened yesterday when Adrian, uh, from or tried to join a call. I think something has happened from our IT side.
Yeah, same, same thing. Same was the screenshot shared by. Even when I took an interview yesterday, so candidate said that he had to sign in.
to prove his identity and then he was able to join the call.
How are they expected to prove their identity?
I don't know, I mean, they just need to sign in.
Sign in with the account, the invite was sent to and try again, so they need to sign in with their account.
Something has happened.
Call Ramesh.
The.
I'm stopping the recording.
So, how did you, how did you, how did you get Adrian? Yeah, stop the recording. How did you get Adrian on the call?